there's a business in town that is
determined to ensure your feet are good
to go whether you're ready to play a
sport or with your grandkids let's head
to the Good Feet store the sponsors of
the segment
welcome to the Good Feet store where
America's arch support experts help
people relieve foot back and knee pain
we've created a three-step system that
will help improve your quality of life
and no matter what kind of life you walk
you need Good Feet I would say 95 of
people benefit from our Orthotics from
your young soccer player all the way to
your retired person who wants to live
their golden life this is what makes the
Good Feet store unique our patented
three-step system is what separates us
from the industry good feed Orthotics
support the four arches so so many
people don't even know that we have four
arches once you support the four arches
that's what creates the change helps
align your body and helps you be better
balanced so what we do we offer a free
fitting and it's customized to your arch
type in your needs because we do carry
over 30 different styles with different
flexibilities to fit your lifestyle so
when you come in for a free fitting all
you got to do is bring in some of your
normal Footwear choices the free fitting
will start with an ink footprint to see
the relationship of your feet with the
ground then we'll take a measurement
we'll go ahead and customize your
three-step system and we'll come out
have you try it out and walk and see how
you feel it's about feeling and learning
what good feet are so you see it here
evenly distributed weight toes line up
nice and neat and you see a well-defined
arch so what kind of feet do you have
the Good Feet experts are happy to show
and help you here we care about our
clients we get them out of foot pain and
the most rewarding piece of what I do is
to see that person smile that person
able to walk again able to do the
activities that they weren't able to do
for many many years I have stories from
younger clients who come in and suffer
from hip pain back pain to the older
clients that just want to get out and
enjoy their retired life and play golf
perhaps or go out and walk the dog just
our normal activities
so that to me is the best part of what
we do here at Good Feet
make a consultation to see us online or
head over and we're ready to give you a
free fitting here at the Good Feet store
thank you to the good Feast store for
sponsoring this segment call the number
right there on your screen or visit
their website they also have a very
special offer for you free Comfort
cushions with purchase of our three-step
system we'll be right back